after days of hurricane footage
depicting countless examples of human
bravery and compassion we probably need
something really petty to balance it out
like Morning Joe yeah for like a
nine-year-old he hands it in the window
it's better when you see but you have to
just take it because if the president
putting it in the wrong place you know
it is your baggage man you know and
you're like okay well I didn't you got a
hole light back there
the flatbed part you mean you can put it
that's where you're useful if you have
like eggs or carrying stuff it up yeah
thank you buckets why they call it a
truck hmm they really are America's
Sweethearts if by sweethearts you mean
hemorrhoids
now I see this as a positive after
seeing Donald Trump handled the
catastrophe they can't call him racist
or Hitler or unstable mocking a photo op
is all they got when a response is this
feeble it says that the cartoon
demonization of Trump is petering out
after seeing how Americans and the
president reacted to Harvey it's dawning
on them that America ain't so bad in
that it's getting better perhaps even
under Trump case in point
not just Dianne Feinstein but Nancy
Pelosi have defended President Trump
suggesting we should give the guy a
chance
then there's the rise an immediate fall
of an tyfa has any violent mob had a
shorter honeymoon than that pile of dung
they made Occupy Wall Street look like
Gandhi so as the hate blows over Dems
realize it's a losing proposition so
there disowning it on the streets and in
their own party what caused this well
maybe Harvey had an effect beyond the
obvious damage it rewound toxic
perspectives what we saw was good stuff
coming from bad morality in motion the
hurricane took the wind out of the
whiners leaving only a few chortling
chuckle buckets bolstered by forced
laughter of co-hosts quietly wishing for
a better gig hurricane Harvey has moved
on and so with it so has America Morning
Joe hasn't
um it's easy Jesse to make fun of a
photo-op they're always clumsy and
stupid he was nearly I guess he was like
holding cement to the guy instead of
putting into the back of the truck oh my
god what low-hanging fruit for even them
I mean that's low-hanging fruit even for
those low hanging fruit pickers I mean
technically yeah it's a gaff all right
fine you know what gaff he didn't make
he didn't accidentally call himself
Muslim he didn't go golfing after an
American was beheaded didn't bow to a
Saudi King didn't do the wave in Cuba
after a terrorist attack didn't final a
fundraiser after Benghazi so you know
what I'm gonna give this president a
pass on that I guess maybe you know you
should have handed it right through
there but I think in a photo op people
hand you things you don't know what
you're doing maybe he just wanted to say
hi to the driver and that's what him and
he wanted to get the guy in the picture
okay that's all it's a photo op you know
what and to act like the president's
never seen a pickup truck before the
guy's done all of his business around
construction sites his whole life he's a
real estate developer you never think
he's seen hard hats or a flatbed of a
truck Mieke
I don't know about Joe but Myka grew up
in Georgetown and Manhattan to act like
she's you know down with like pickup
trucks is crazy she I mean I mean I'm
not really left
I might drove a pickup truck him there's
a lot of damage but the same time she
has really no legs to stand on Dana we
saw a lot of I mean it was an uplifting
period as much as tragedy there was yeah
we saw the America that we knew was real
as opposed to with the media portrayed
and it just seems to me that it must
Drive morning Jo crazy and also that
instead of making fun of them there's
plenty of other news yeah yeah I mean
it's not like we're hurting for subjects
in fact there's so many that we would
love to cover that we can't get to on a
show and I think that they're what
they're doing also is their seeding the
ground on policy so while they're making
fun of things like this or basically not
arguing for their the issues that they
care about
so I also thought about when your your
list was great
oh I could go on Mary go on you know
photo often in a disaster areas they're
always difficult yeah but what what they
fail to remember is that so they're in
their comfort of their yeah where are
they in New York Washington DC and
there's a president actually traveled
there he was with the people and the
people there
loved it yeah Republican or Democrat I'm
sure they
happy to see him what do you think Juan
was Morning Joe just being petty yeah I
mean I think they're making fun of him
and obviously this whole thing with his
hands I don't know it seems to be in his
head I mean I don't know where it came
from because in the midst of this
written copy had an opportunity you know
to try to make up for what happened on
the first visit and I think he did
pretty well I mean the pictures which is
what you're after if you're the
president you want pictures that convey
to the American people that you do have
empathy in your heart and you can stand
and travel to a place of disaster and
act as the you know I guess comforter in
chief if you will that's what he did
when the president is is learning how to
be president he's learning how to be a
politician and he's had some missteps
but it's interesting because the
Democrats are constantly failing at
politics and instead of learning about
contrasts because you can actually
defeat your opponent if you have a
contrasting series of opinions you know
if you constantly bash him and then one
time he does something right you say oh
yeah absolutely did something right and
then to Dana's point if he fails on
policy you could say I really let us
down right man you did so good when you
wait like yeah you guys have Kanye with
if they don't come through with the
money for Texas then you can go back and
we play that it's time to do it but now
they weaken their position and they're
the party that cries wolf but does any
the money is interesting because I is
that part of the budget or not and we'll
see what the present and we've got don't
forget hurricane Irma coming out down on
Florrick